so ken uh the job numbers are
you were talking about it before we came
on the air yeah and this is a
um i thought i knew something i i'm
learning i knew nothing
i couldn't i mean i i've got in my mind
i've got states that are wide open like
our state of tennessee's wide open and
then you've got
you know the communist state of
california where everything's shut down
by a draconian governor
right and so i figure the entire economy
is just sitting on the sidelines sitting
on their hands in some of these states
and the economy's booming in the other
states but you're saying these
numbers coming out the federal numbers
coming out across the whole nation
blending these different states together
obviously in these numbers
the job market is really good it's way
better than you think and here's the
good news dave these numbers say it's
going to absolutely explode
in the next few months in the next
quarter here's where we are right now
end of february 6.7 million private
sector jobs were posted
that's up from 6.1 million
at the end of december so as we went
into the new year that's how many jobs
so we're seeing a nice trend in
private sector jobs that are posted all
right and here's the way of looking at
that
eight percent more job openings in
february 2021 than there were in
february 2020. now some of you are going
okay i'm trying to remember when did
covet shutdown start
really in march in the month of february
obviously towards the end of february we
were learning new information and things
really ground to a halt in march dave
but we had negative unemployment in
february 3.4
oh we had 3.4 but that's historical that
was the lowest unemployment rate in the
history of the modern era where they
really took
uh those those data and they really
crunched it so we had
the greatest unemployment rate if you
will not greatest or the lowest
the best it ever performed so now we're
seeing more jobs so what we're seeing is
the united states economy is creating
new jobs so we lost 40 million jobs
in the covet downturn right that's right
but now so what and the unemployment
rate today is what
low six as well that's what it was
reported last month we're waiting on
those numbers to come out in april
i think you're going to see those
numbers drop into the low fives
you might see it in the four there's no
way to really predict that but based on
the overall economy from a jobs
perspective has bounced back
it's bouncing back it's not even
finished let me tell you where this is
happening dave
in the areas of manufacturing pharmacy
construction and logistics
and think logistics a lot of technical
jobs there you're seeing
50 growth in jobs so what's going to
happen in the next few months
i think we're going to get very close to
where we were in february of 2020
pre-pandemic
where there were more jobs available
than there were people were unemployed
why is this matter well number one
you're getting a steady diet of negative
news all the time that the sky is
falling out because i mean
i don't even watch the news and i
thought it was worse than that no and
the second thing is is understand folks
there are still a lot of states remember
california new york new jersey just
giving you some examples not a political
statement this is a fact
they're still not fully opened up and if
you look at the hardest hit sector in
the american job
economy was what we'd call leisure so
that would be your bars your restaurants
uh hotels certainly the airline industry
they're not back so when we see
hopefully
a full comeback in the summer i think
we're going to see one of the greatest
history greatest periods of job
expansion
that means companies offering more jobs
and think of the economy dave and how
jobs that didn't exist a year ago so
what does that mean to a guy that's out
there listening who
uh doesn't have a job it means you
better be ready and that's why you need
to come to my get hired event
i just slipped that in there right there
april 27 no but yeah
but i mean does this mean that that guy
that's out there doesn't have a job
right now
he really should be looking and looking
different and better because people are
hiring and it's almost
it's almost full up it's exactly right
and it's only going to increase so this
i mean when it's three point something
or four point something unemployment
economists call that full employment yes
even though there's technically people
not working it's like everybody who
wants to work is working and to your
some that don't want to work and here's
what happens in that situation
that we described as last february
people will start to pay you more
the market value for a job goes up we
saw this last year where
young people coming out of college were
getting paid more
than people that were already on the job
and experience why because the demand
this is a supply demand issue just like
in housing
or any other commodity supply demand we
are about ready to move into a place
where it is going to be a really good
environment for the job seeker
for you to get hired and make more money
bigger shovel
get out of debt faster and position
yourself so
it also works for not only someone who's
sitting there unemployed today but
someone who just wants to change jobs
yes sir
a lot of opportunity a lot of
opportunity i want to make more money i
want to do something different
and so getting qualified right now
getting prepared for this
you've got to have your head on a swivel
the job market's heating up and it's
going to get better
anybody who's intentional about where i
want to go
why i want to go there what i want to do
when i get there
now's the time